und wir begrüßen jetzt bei uns im Studio
ist Rainer wendt-vorsitzender der
Deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft einen
schönen guten Morgen
zunächst einmal shit happens was haben
Sie gedacht als der klimaaktivist so
reagiert hat auf diesen Notfall die
Rettungsfahrzeuge kommen nicht durch die
Frau liegt auf der Intensivstation
fürchtet um ihr Bein die erste Reaktion
darauf folgte zwar eine Entschuldigung
aber die erste Reaktion war shit happens
was ging ihm durch den Kopf mir ging
durch den Kopf ja genau so sind diese
Typen zumindest die extremistischen
Typen unter ihnen man darf ja auch nicht
alle über einen Kamm scheren aber die
Wahrheit ist und deshalb bin ich Bild
auch für die Berichterstattung und auch
für die Wortwahl sehr dankbar sind
Chaoten es sind Extremisten es sind
Kriminelle und es sind eben keine
harmlosen Aktivisten oder klimarretter
oder so ein Zeug das ist ein richtig
knallharter Extremist und von der
entschuldigung ich glaube ihm kein
einziges Wort die Polizei hat jetzt
Strafanzeige erstattet reicht das die
Polizei hat schon über 1.900
Strafanzeigen erstattet das heißt in
Berlin arbeiten nicht nur bastbar viele
Polizeikräfte mehr als 100.000
Einsatzstunden sind das schon investiert
worden und die Staatsanwaltschaften
arbeiten jetzt die Gerichte Arbeiten
versuchen mit Geldstrafen und mit
anderen Möglichkeiten das in den Griff
zu bekommen das wird nicht gelingen ohne
politische Unterstützung und auch das
hat ihr Beitrag ja deutlich gemacht
sowohl die Grünen als auch die Linken
haben hier eine riesige Mitverantwortung
es sind ihre Vorfeldorganisation und
wenn jetzt die Frau Giffey
beispielsweise die reagierende
Bürgermeisterin in Berlin
Krokodilstränen vergisst da kann ich nur
sagen liebe Frau Giffey sie liegen genau
mit diesen Parteien im koalitionsbett
das müssen sie klären es ist ihre
Aufgabe in der Koalition dafür zu sorgen
dass sich nicht nur einzelne
SPD-Politiker sondern SPD Grüne und
Linke von diesen Chaoten eindeutig
distanzieren das tun sie nämlich immer
noch nicht also einmal ein bisschen
distanzieren und am nächsten Tag wieder
weitermachen und diese Chaoten fördern
das passt nun mal nicht zusammen wenn
das eben gerade auch in unseren Beitrag
gesehen Klaus Strunz hat gesagt man muss
fürchten dass da eine grüne RAF sich
bildet wie weit ist man in dieser
Bildung schon wie radikal sind einige
der Aktivisten also Klaus Strunz hat
ausdrücklich recht ich habe das auch vor
wenigen Wochen schon gesagt Teile dieser
Bewegung sind mit Sicherheit auf dem Weg
in den Terrorismus es gibt viele
Kennzeichen dafür erstens die
Menschenverachtung die sie antreibt die
Ideologie die Rücksichtslosigkeit aber
auch die Bereitschaft zur
Gewaltanwendung und was vor allen Dingen
sie auch immer wieder kennzeichnet ist
sie wollen erstens ein politischen
Systemwechsel und sie wollen vor allen
Dingen den Start erpressen das heißt sie
verlangen ja von der Bundesregierung vom
Deutschen Bundestag sofortiges Handeln
in ihrem Sinne und das ist unfassbar in
einer Demokratie der eine politische
Entscheidung steht am Ende eines
politischen Willensbildungsprozesses von
demokratisch gewählten Politikerinnen
und Politikern und nicht für ein paar
von ein paar Extremisten auf der Straße
da darf der Staat überhaupt nicht darauf
reagieren er darf ihn um keinen
Millimeter Entgegenkommen was kann jetzt
die kann noch tun was muss von der
Justiz vielleicht auch kommen also die
Polizei tut was sie kann das macht sich
sehr sehr gut das heißt sie sichert den
Stau ab sie holt die Leute von der
Straße sein Einsatz dauert in der Regel
anderthalb Stunden dann sind die wieder
weg in der Regel werden dann aber
Personalien aufgenommen und Anzeigen
geschrieben das ist ein bisschen wenig
wir würden gerne mehr tun nämlich zu
Beginn einer solchen Aktion das sind ja
immer so Blöcke wenn die eine Woche
beispielsweise Vorhersagen in dieser
Woche wollen wir stören und werden wir
Brücken und Straßen blockieren dann muss
am ersten Tag ein bisschen alle
diejenigen die daran teilnehmen sofort
in Unterbindungsgewahrsam genommen
werden das kann die Polizei aber nicht
alleine tun dazu braucht es immer die
Anordnung eines Richters ich wünschte
mir dass die Gerichte davon Gebrauch
machen und zwar so dass sie dann
tatsächlich die ganze Woche in Gewahrsam
sind und nicht nur für ein paar Stunden
bis sagten ja viele einfach nur die
Nerven die kleben sich festmachen
Gemälde kaputt das nervt einfach nur man
hat den Eindruck jetzt mit dem was jetzt
passiert ist wir beobachten hierbei Bild
weiter sehr genau wie es der
Schwerverletzten Frau auch geht ist ein
ganz anderes Level erreicht worden ich
finde nicht es ist purer Zufall dass
erst jetzt etwas passiert ist es ist
übrigens auch purer Zufall dass es noch
längst keine Toten gegeben hat das hat
da haben die Glück gehabt und die
Menschen haben auch Glück gehabt aber es
ist eben Zufall jetzt ist ein Level
erreicht wo alle tief betroffen sind wir
haben das lange vorhergesehen und auch
immer vorhergesagt wer in dieser Weise
in den Straßenverkehr eingreift der
riskiert Menschenleben und das macht es
ebenso dramatisch und man hat den
Eindruck es muss immer erst etwas
passieren bevor etwas geschieht bisschen
bislang haben wir von Rot-Rot-Grün ganz
ganz halbherzige Distanzierungen auch
der Bundeskanzler sagt es hat nicht
seinen Beifall gefunden ja was ist das
denn für eine Schlafmützigkeit
entschuldigung das ist doch keine keine
richtige Distanzierung ich erwarte eine
klare Verurteilung dieser Taten auch
wenn er Bundeskanzler und SPD Mann ist
machen wir es ganz konkret ihre
konkreten Forderungen an Politik an
Justiz was muss jetzt passieren die
Politik muss sich klar von diesen Leuten
abgrenzen und zwar alle auch die Linken
die Grünen die Sozialdemokraten da darf
es keine Zweifel daran geben dass die
das verurteilen zweitens die Justiz muss
stärker von der Möglichkeit des
unterbindungsgewahrsams Gebrauch machen
und drittens ja sowohl Justiz
Justizvollzug aber auch Polizei und vor
allen Dingen in Berlin müssen gestärkt
werden damit sie ihre Arbeit besser
machen können Rainer wenn vielen
herzlichen Dank für Ihre deutlichen
Worte an diesem Morgen
[Musik]